people of the internet retro recontour
here welcome back to harry potter and
the chamber of secrets
this is our let's play series guys we
just escaped from aragog
it was a crazy epic battle if you didn't
get a chance to watch it yet go back
watch that one then jump back in here i
think this is evening
five or evening four and then we're
about to start i think i think we're
about to start
day six i could be wrong on that but i
think we're getting ready to start day
six so i'm gonna go ahead and end the
day here and we'll see what the next day
has in store oh
i must have slept in oh no come on
each match i mean guys i think
they should cut him a little bit of
slack the dude just
battled a giant freaking spider mostly
by himself
in the video game by the way ron and the
flying car didn't show up till it was
too late now apparently harry is late
for
uh the quidditch match let's take a look
here see if we can uh let's see what is
the next thing we need to find a
wizard's hat dropped while taking a
shortcut in the grand staircase
if found please return to this nose
board okay yeah we should be able to
find that one
but i don't know it feels kind of urgent
right now i think we should probably
just head straight down there
[Music]
well there's still a lot of students
hanging out here so
maybe the quidditch match maybe we're
not maybe we're not too late
sorry i didn't mean to hit you right
there uh but you know what i am
going to take this opportunity to grab a
few birdy bop beans
oh and apparently we need some health as
well look at that guys not good
one more pumpkin pasty should do it okay
fine no more pumpkin pasties
all right i mean since i i guess it
feels like the game wants us to rush but
you know what i'm just gonna take a look
around
i'm gonna take a look around and see if
i can't find the uh
wizard's hat in an obvious spot
i'm not gonna start going through all
the rooms here
i mean and to be honest that's probably
where it is
in one of these little corridors on the
side
uh but i am just gonna take a peek here
on each floor and make sure it's not
somewhere obvious because if it is we
could just
grab it really quick and be done you
know what i am going to check this spot
right here
i just i don't know dude i just get a
feeling i just got a feeling that maybe
this is where it is
come on come on tell me i'm right tell
me i'm right how about done here
didn't say something about a shortcut in
the grand staircase
look i'm sorry guys
i'm sorry if i don't have you guys are
like you just read it oh
dude let's go
let's go man that is awesome
i told you dude i just had like this
feeling maybe i'm remembering all the
years
ago when i played it as a kid
because uh honestly like i haven't
looked at any guides or anything this
time around so i
that was totally a guess it just kind of
i don't know if it
felt like a spot that the wizard hat
might be hanging out i don't know
now let's see can i get back i mean you
know what i'm already here i might as
well use these for
because they're worth so many birdie bop
beans
as we'll go ahead and fully exhaust them
and we might actually i don't think
these ever give any help
i think they're always birdie about
beans
looks like it looks like it more betty
bought
every flavor beans
i mean look at that already up to 42
here at like five or something when we
first started so
not bad at all all right let's head back
around there watch out for those fire
crabs though
because they are going to be actually
can we just go out this way
yes there we go perfect all right now
can we get some help right here
come on how about some health all right
last one
all right let's head down and see uh how
late we are for the quidditch map
harry big match against slytherin today
i'm glad it's you that's doing it after
all that flying about and what we found
out last night i can't think straight
thank you ron
thank you we can't tell anyone about the
diary
somebody's taking that into account why
hagrid was expelled 50 years ago
the voice i just heard it again didn't
you
harry hermione's still not petrified
thing i've got to go to the light oh
here we go
yes this is a stand we're getting close
to end game here
but why she got to go to the library
because that's what hermione does
when in doubt go to the library anyway
harry
you'd better get a move on the match
i love how all of a sudden it's like
yeah i mean you're not really that late
but can we just talk for a minute about
how truly terrifying chamber of secrets
is
like i can remember reading that as a
kid
and just being so into it but like
legit terrified why is he hearing this
voice and no one else is
like nobody else is hearing this what
is going on and you know sometimes with
things like that once you find out the
answer it's like okay now it's less
scary
and it's certainly not as uh what's the
word it's certainly not a suspenseful
anymore
but dude it's just as terrifying when
you find out what it is if not more
terrifying when you
realize that it's a giant freaking snake
traveling through the pipes of hogwarts
i mean terrifying dude terrified
all right quidditch match against
slytherin and i'm pretty sure
they are another undefeated team so we
haven't lost slytherin hasn't lost
let's do this
all right come on harry let's let's end
this one quick welcome to what may turn
out to be the match of the year
the match of the year
[Music]
[Applause]
by the way guys we are definitely going
to play with this world cup
we are absolutely gonna play quidditch
world cup
as part of our harry potter replay
series
as we uh work our way up to
the release of hogwarts legacy
whoa man this is a really challenging
force right here
[Applause]
oh this is gonna be tough we did not
catch him even with our boots
and i don't even know how you do this
even if you don't miss any i don't see
how you do this perfectly
you guys are like okay retro okay
sure it's not
especially when you are doing like this
okay maybe maybe it is sensitive enough
maybe it is
because whenever you use the boost it is
like highly highly sensitive
you just barely look left or right and
it really
jumps to the spot
wow wow like straight up
i have no idea where we're supposed to
go
i'm not about to use that boost i know
i've had it for a while okay there we go
now we're in a little straight away here
[Applause]
he's afraid of that man
no way
is that part of the story
i'm so no when's the quidditch cop
never mind harry there's always next
year hermione will be gutted when i tell
her about slithering get in the cup
what hermione wasn't at the match no
i haven't i'm serious i wonder i don't
know i think that's how it has to happen
i'm stuck in a book somewhere anyway
i'm worn out hopefully
because i'm tempted to like reload the
save and retry it but now
it's all good i'm gonna stick with it
all right ron you're off to bed okay
well what i'm gonna do
is i'm gonna head back up to the
gryffindor common room
and get a wizard card for finding the
wizard hat
[Music]
by the way guys uh i if you can't tell
if you don't really ever look at the
webcam closely then you probably didn't
even notice but i
kind of rearranged the room ever so
slightly
and i absolutely love it except for
there's one
big problem and if it's if you look
right above my head here
you can see my light reflecting in the
uh artwork that i have back there it's
actually a print from the last of us my
favorite game of all time
and if i i could rearrange i think i'll
have to do one of two things i'll have
to either move that picture somewhere
else relocate it
or i'm gonna have to switch back to like
a slightly off
off-center camera angle so i would have
to either move it to my left or to my
right i'd prefer it to be on my left
but in the setup of the room that i'm in
then you just see like this
this door over here and it looks it
doesn't look aesthetically pleasing
see i think about all the little things
for you guys
but then part of me is like i don't know
that kind of looks cool
all the backlighting people have these
days
it's like i got a little halo above me
there so it's gonna be like
what kind of lighting is that dude
where'd you get that
no not any rgb special lighting nothing
like that it's just uh
a ring light shining directly into a
reflective surface
i like held up some other uh oh wait i
need to go
i like held up a pillow in front of it
and held up a a book with like colors on
the front
anything non-reflective it doesn't shine
back so
i kind of like my last of us painting or
it's not a painting uh print i kind of
like it being
in the backdrop but i don't know i might
just have to move it to like
this right wall beside me here if you
guys have any thoughts let me know what
you think go back to an
off off center camera angle and keep
the last of us artwork where it is or
just just move the artwork
because i really do i think i like this
camera angle a lot better
uh and the lighting setup i think looks
a little bit better as well okay so next
thing we need to find dragon hide gloves
last known location the entrance hall if
found please return to this notice board
that sounds like a pretty easy one to
find i think i might run back down there
to the entrance hall but first let's see
what wizard card we have received here
who do we have ethelrid
the ever ready wait doesn't he usually
say say their name
he didn't say the name that time
weird uh ethelrid the ever ready
medieval dates unknown famous for taking
offense at nothing
and cursing innocent bystanders
died in gal no idea how to pronounce how
to pronounce that
g-a-o-l
you have not collected this card yet so
we're still
like we've still got quite a few we've
got five to go on that page
what five six seven on that page another
five on that page
oh man we got a punch on that page bunch
on that page
and we only need two more on this page
so even though i feel like we're getting
pretty close to the end of the game you
still have a lot of wizard cards so i'm
gonna head and
go ahead that's what i'm trying to say
go ahead and head back down to the
entrance hall
see if we can find the glove
[Music]
okay it is still daytime right so we'll
have something else to do
in the evening hours this is
that's probably when they're going to
discover that hermione's been petrified
as my guess because they already talked
about her not being at the quidditch
match
harry's like what she wasn't there so i
would say that will be my
activity for this evening now so
entrance hallway is this considered the
entrance hall
or actually they probably consider this
the entrance hall yep
you know what who cares that i'm at the
very end of the game i'm not very end
getting close to the end though
and now i know where most things are
still not everything but hey
don't make fun of me guys don't make fun
of me i've told you before i'm terrible
with directions in both real life
and in game so i when i say i can't wait
to get lost in hogwarts legacy
little do you guys know i i actually
mean it like literally
i can't wait to get lost oh an incendio
right here
what's inside another wizard card
number 89 alberta toot hill see there he
goes he says the
he says the number and the name alberta
tudhill winner of the all
england wizarding dueling competition of
famously overcame the favorite samson
wiblin with a blasting curse
1391-1483 number 89 right there very
cool
all right so okay that door's locked
that one's set keep out this entire time
okay so remember we're looking for like
that little uh glove
and they said entrance hall which i
guess could technically be
anywhere wait can we actually go in here
i was about to say i thought i had tried
it before
why doesn't it say lock then pretty sure
i said that the last time i tried it as
well
okay so looks like nowhere
in the main part of the entrance hall
okay that's locked let's see with this
going to the great hall can we actually
go in there right now
why are you guys keeping the great hall
during the middle of the day house elves
don't want us going in there or
something right now
they're like no we're preparing for the
next meal
no students allowed all right so i think
the only way we didn't try yet
is this way
come on how about what
where in the world
all right i guess there it is dude let's
go
right there dragon hide gloves
awesome all right back up to gryffindor
tower we go
okay this time let's see if he actually
says the name of the wizard card on here
okay the next thing we need to find is
gadding with ghouls copy of getting with
ghouls could be
anywhere in a classroom oh man so they
want us to
i mean at first i'm going to guess
gildaway lockharts since he wrote the
book but
they could surprise us it could be
somewhere else so it found please return
to the notice
okay let's see which wizard card we've
got this time
[Music]
oh he didn't say it that time either i
wonder if it's a
if i hit a glitch or if he has never
said it when you get the the cards from
finding the items
well fine i'll tell you guys anyway uh
felix summerbee 1447-1508
inventor of cheering charms pretty uh
short and sweet one right there not much
else to say all right so let's read the
next one again
uh let's see anywhere in a classroom
you know what let's go for it guys let's
go for it
okay so far our instincts have paid off
we're gonna try again here and we're
gonna guess
that it is in the defense against the
dark arts classroom
okay here we are let's see
not in this little area while we're here
you know what
you know what we gotta do while we're
here
might as well go ahead and gather a few
more
birdie bop beans go ahead and go through
these doors here
and come on let's see if it's in here
well there's a couple books right there
i don't think that's the book we're
looking for though dude it is so weird
when the music goes out
it's just eerily quiet all right well
my instincts may have led us wrong this
time guys
it should be hopping around like the
other so at least they do make it
obvious
what are these little things anyway it's
like some
house crest they're just positioned all
over the school
just these little like i don't know are
they are they picture frames
it looks like it's it's the crest of
some kind but why would they have them
all for the school oh it cracks me up
all right so we were wrong on that one
let's go back and check out some of the
other classrooms
all right so i mean the fact that it
could be in any classroom
we're we're kind of just it's a matter
of trial and error here
so i'm gonna go ahead and check the
other one on this floor
just to make sure oh man there's no way
they'd put it in here right
they wouldn't be that cruel and it's
much easier to check the classrooms
during the day
than it is at night because you don't
have to worry about the hands of glory
that will take away all your beans
as they zap you well i mean you can
avoid it you just have to be
as you guys have seen in the previous
videos you have to use stealth and
you also have to worry about all the
little books flying around when you're
running through here but now we don't
worry about that okay this is not a
classroom so
just gonna turn wait what is in here
i want to check this out
wait is this where i was earlier yeah it
is
okay not in here i could i could have
probably got more beans from those
little
baskets in there but we're on a mission
right now guys we are on a mission
and that mission is to find oh wait
incendio challenge chambers i don't
think i don't think it lets you back in
here
but i was wrong it does indeed let you
back in here
yeah i don't think it's in any of the
classrooms like this
i think it's it's the classrooms that
are strictly just that classrooms
they're not like a challenge chamber
area
or anything like this so we're just
gonna go right back
all right so we need to just look for
ones that are like just classrooms
where you don't have a loading screen or
anything
so i always cut out the loading screens
for you guys you guys don't have to
see them and worry about it but trust me
there is way
too much loading in this game i even
remember
playing it when i was playing it on
gamecube as a kid like that it drove me
crazy all the loading
just so many loading screens okay wait
is this the right
area dude where are all those classrooms
wait have i opened this one yet
it kind of looks like i have and it kind
of looks like i haven't i don't think i
have because i think once you've opened
them they like fly all the way up
yep just like that so now let's go ahead
and get this wizard card here
[Music]
number 96 hengest of woodcroft
oh well we almost have all of them on
this page we only need one more ingest
of woodcraft
or woodcraft i'm sorry medieval dates
unknown
driven away from his home by non-magical
persecutors
hingist is supposed to have settled in
scotland where he founded the village of
hogsmeade ah
very interesting the three broomsticks
in is alleged to be
hinges old home ah very cool
i do not remember his name hingist of
woodcroft
the founder of hogsmeade that's an
interesting one
okay so that's locked
that's locked that's locked all right
fine then looking for a classroom
and i've totally already forgot the item
that we're looking for see i don't want
to go in there because
i think it's gonna be it's gonna be one
of these types of classrooms
i'm almost positive
i could be totally wrong but i'm almost
positive that's going to be
one like this oh no
when it goes on top of the desk you
can't get it
that's so ridiculous all right well
let's go on back out
and we'll try the next one i think
there's a couple of classrooms on this
area right here okay that one's locked
about here yes another classroom
ah dude there is that thing man
you should probably be keeping track of
which ones we've checked and which of us
we haven't so this is the first floor
we already checked defense against the
dark guards let's check one more right
here
oh man it could be in any classroom
all right well i guess we've got to
check the transfiguration one then
even though like my my gut been
listening to the gut a lot tonight guys
we'll see if it uh cause i don't think
it's gonna be in here
okay look to the left look to the right
listen to the sinister music that's
playing
got a couple students still hanging out
in here
yeah just like i thought these robes are
really itchy aren't they
why yes that's exactly what i was
thinking
nope okay well let's go on
start going back up now so we checked
the first floor it's clear we checked
we did not check charms and the library
actually no we did check this one yeah
we didn't check the library but i don't
think there are any classrooms there
now we we also check three with the
defense against the dark arts
all right so number four history of
magic this is the classroom here
that's locked okay classroom here maybe
yes here we go
[Music]
okay oh wow we got the jackpot right
here we did not find the item that we're
looking for but we've got
two chests that we have not yet opened
most likely going to yield two more
wizard cards here
let's see what we got here
number 82 hey ravenclaw
82. nice co-founder of hogwarts gave her
name to one of the four
hogwarts houses medieval dates unknown
pretty pretty straightforward on that
one okay so we're gonna need a
scourge
or scourgify even though i guess they
call it scourge in the game
another wizard card
number 99 daisy dotterage yeah i
remember that name daisy daughter it's
1467 to 1555.
first landlady of the leaky cauldron
the leaky cauldron you hear that erin
the leaky cauldron all right well
i mean it was definitely worth going in
here but
still on the hunt for our next item okay
so and i think that's the only
spot you can go on this one right here i
mean here you can sneak
under but i think this see does this
lead us into a classroom
this is where i went before i'm gonna go
right back through
and we're gonna keep going up it's gonna
be hilarious it's gonna be the floor
like right next to gryffindor it's gonna
be the sixth floor
okay non-magical studies that door is
locked
okay come on classrooms maybe yeah there
we go
we've already been here before okay so
we've opened that
and we've opened that no sign of
our item oh man
okay can we go in here nope that one's
locked as well
all right like i said it's gonna be the
sixth floor
ancient rooms classroom here maybe
yes there we go and there it is guys
see i made it way too hard getting with
ghouls right there
and okay okay this was definitely worth
it though because look at this look at
this
we are just racking up on the wizard
cards right now
racking up on the wizard cards see who
do we have here
number 71 queen maeve queen maeve
legendary witch who trained young
sorcerers in ireland prior to the
establishment of hogwarts school of
witchcraft and wizardry
medieval dates unknown
very cool very cool and we just unlocked
more health with that right there
and then we also need to pull up defendo
and use it on this chest
go ahead and search that and while we're
here i need to check the next classroom
too if there's any other
checks on this floor leopoldina
smithwick
leopoldina smithwick 1829 to 1910. all
right here we go
another late 1800s witch first british
first british witch to referee a
quidditch match
so i guess the only chance we'd see her
is if we're uh
playing a lot of quidditch which fingers
crossed guys
fingers crossed surely
there's gonna be quidditch surely
there's gonna be quidditch in hogwarts
legacy
all right i'm not gonna go through all
the desks for one bean each
i'm just not gonna do it i am gonna
check this classroom though to make sure
that oh yep i saw one right away
straight ahead
straight ahead cast incendio
oh wait no defendo yeah whoops
whoops
all right let's open that up another
wizard god
what do we have here number 83
1889 to 1987 seeker for england
quidditch team holds british record for
fastest capture of snitch during game
three
and a half seconds that is incredible
roderick plumpton
had to be one of those situations where
you know there was a lot of luck
involved it just
went right to him or he he just spotted
it immediately off
off the rip i got another one in this
room here
number 31 balfour blaine balfour blaine
1566-1629
established the committee on
experimental charms
man some of these are so i mean it's
cool that
she wrote all these for the game but i i
wish they would have
like set a baseline for information that
they wanted on all of them because
some of them are just so like okay
okay like there they were their famous
witch and wizard for that
all right i think we already got this
this is the first one we went in right
yeah
yep all right so let's head back up
to gryffindor tower once more and i'm
kind of curious how many more items we
have to go
we might just go ahead and try to knock
them all out before our next uh before
we
hit the evening hours here but who knows
could be a lot more
wattle bird
all righty back to the bulletin board we
go
more items here we go uh okay holidays
with hacks copy of holidays with hacks
fell out of an owl package
so it could be anywhere are you
serious if found please return to this
notice board
well if it was an owl package i mean
that's
outside right it's gotta be outside
right
let's see what wizard card we got
1959 to present gaspard shingleton
celebrated inventor of the self stirring
cauldron gaspard shingleton 1959 to
the present self-steering cauldron
i mean could let's be honest here man
with magic
like do you really have to have a
self-stirring cauldron
like couldn't it be like mrs weasley's
house you can enchant the uh
like couldn't you enchant your spoon
to stir the cauldron
maybe it's something like where
a self-stirring cauldron would be like
magic that
you don't have to exert so you don't
have to think about it
it's just it's just automatic it's it's
some other
form of magic that you don't have to
spend any of your energy on i don't know
that's the best i got let me know what
you guys think down in the comments
if you have any theories on why a
self-stirring cauldron would be needed
like why couldn't you just enchant a
spoon or something
which you probably could enjoy the spoon
okay so
an owl package you guys they say it
could be
anywhere i'm gonna start with the most
logical places first i'm gonna go
outside like
if i was thinking owl package i don't
think you can go to the allergy in this
game
so we're gonna go and look around
outside regardless after i
after i get this item even if it's not
the last one uh we'll move on from there
we're not going to uh i'm not just gonna
keep going for all these items
especially we don't know
how many more we have to go
but first things first we need to head
outside
and look around i mean what do you think
hagrid's hut first maybe
the quidditch area we just came from
quidditch area
all right i'm gonna try the quidditch
area first just because it is so small
and it's another book that we're looking
for remember
and unlike the uh i think in the ps2
version
you could like roam freely all around
here it didn't just like
jump to the next loading zone like this
herbology greenhouse three
anywhere over here i'm just gonna check
all the easy to look places first before
we start going like
into the herbology greenhouse and all
that
to flying practice oh dude i bet it
maybe you have to fly to get to it
can i just run around here
how far can i go before oh then send you
back
okay wait a second hagrid's hut yeah
forbidden forest this way
let's check thoroughly around hagrid's
hut now we already had
one item that was here
it was like right back here okay so not
going to the same place twice i see an
owl package an owl lost wait can you go
in here that's locked
i was about to say what dude
oh i just heard like a frog or something
we're looking for a book not a frog book
sounds book sounds
and we we've already had an item in the
greenhouse as well so that's why i'm
less
inclined to think that it's there i
wonder if we have to fly to it man
[Music]
let's see the flying practice how do you
get up to that area where
oh you have to talk to neville right
yeah let's talk to neville right here
and tell them we want to do the uh
the racing because to do the racing yeah
you like stand up here
oh man what if it was just like waiting
right here
and then i can never remember how you
get out of this area right here
i mean obviously i can end the day but i
don't really want to end the day
[Music]
talk to this it's harry potter isn't it
fancy erase
it's okay i can't see a race uh ten
beans
you know what let's accept it might be
for wizard card
you never know never know there might be
a wizard card in this
how do we know where the end of the race
is or do we know
and we don't have our boost yet
hopefully in hogwarts legacy they they
refine the flying to where
it's not quite so dependent on things
like these
rings like i hope they find a way to
make it require
skill for you to be like think about it
broomstick flying
like what really would make you fly
faster
on a broom is it like how you position
your body like how much you lean
forward you know it's not like it's a
it's a motorcycle or something where you
push a throttle or anything like that
is it dependent on one's magical ability
or what i'd be curious
okay so that wasn't too hard we never
even got a boost here's a wizard card
let's go
i told you guys 24. waffling
albert waffling1899 that's his that's as
late 1800s as you can get right there
uh but 1899 to 1981 famous magical
theoretician theory
theoretician i think i'm pronouncing
that correctly uh he doesn't look like a
happy dude
he looks kind of uh annoyed i love how
these are famous witches and wizard
cards and his
his little bio is literally famous
magical theoretician that's it like
i got to tell you why he was famous just
that he was
trust us on it okay let's race harry
i won't lose this time you won't okay 15
15 beans ooh they're up in the ante
they're up in the antsy
you know what i'm gonna decline this one
because we gotta keep searching
we've got to keep searching for this
book here
so let me talk to neville again
and what if i do gnome toss ain't gnome
dunking
let's do gnome dunking first okay look
all around
look all around make sure there's no
book out here this would be crazy if
they like hid the book behind a menu
like this
like like you have to go to neville
oh come on pick him up pick him up pick
him up parry
all right let's see if we can beat
fred's 300 here
[Music]
nope didn't beat him on that one
oh wow we did 4 15. number 18. uric the
oddball
and we get another wizard card medieval
dates unknown uric the oddball highly
eccentric wizard
who is famed among other things for
wearing a jellyfish for a hat
all right i wonder if that's the only
wizard car we can get from this though
or like if i go even further can i get
more i bet that's it i bet you're gonna
get
i bet you get more for the flying though
i was gonna say i bet you can get one
for each on
all of them let me do the the other
gnome one now
oh see that one completely goes away
okay interesting so they completely go
away
once you have uh once you've like done
everything on that one
why don't you have a go at beating this
that's the same girls
cost 10 beans so the fact that the
flying is still there
tells us that yes there are more
to earn oh wow look at this dude
[Music]
oh just 90. oh there we go 160.
now what do i just keep going oh i get
to throw
all of them no way oh dude we're gonna
get so many points right here
watch this watch this so many points
come on same one right the blue one
again
all right let's grab you which one's the
small the gold one's probably worth the
most right
it's the smallest yeah
oh that's gold that's gold boom
let's go dude we are setting the record
high 310 right now
we got one more throw
oh i messed up on that one i was looking
at where the gold
was instead of where it was going to be
yeah let's take that wizard card right
there
all right who do we got number 15
paracelsus
paracelsus medieval dates unknown very
little listen
are you kidding me then how's he on a
famous wizard card
how is he on a famous wizard card
if very little is known of him
i'm sorry jk rowling or whoever was
whoever wrote these for the game maybe
she had like an intern maybe somebody at
uh working on the game helped write
these but like
you know you're getting to the bottom of
the barrel here when you're like let's
just make
okay we need one more wizard cart guys
here's what we're gonna do
he's medieval don't even have to worry
about the dates like he lived sometime
long long ago
we're gonna call him paracelsus and uh
he was mysterious and that my friends
is why i was famous oh wow
okay so have we done everything on there
now let's see if the flying is
the only thing left oh there's another
gnome tossing
oh my goodness dude all right we'll come
back to that
put a little pin in that guys put a
little pin in that we're not going to
forget about that
now i'm trying to think like
gosh where else would it be outside can
i like go into the quidditch stadium i
don't think so
no way oh my goodness
you guys you guys i messed up i messed
up bad
i just like you you all are seeing this
not in real time but i just had to do
the whole quidditch tutorial
over again and like i couldn't remember
when i saved last so i couldn't just
quit out of the game had to catch the
snitch not once but twice
so anyway i'm exhausted at this point
you guys
are again you're not seeing it in real
time but i'm still trying to find this
book
so i'm trying to think here like
okay it's not outside that would be the
most logical place next most logical
place i feel like would be the great
hall like you know the owls delivering
packages to all the students there
[Music]
but i'm pretty sure we just tried the
great hall a moment ago
and yeah it's locked so
like the fact that it could be anywhere
i'm trying to think where else
would students congregate like a lot of
students congregate maybe the library
i'll check the library
because honestly that is like the last
sort of big location that i can think of
if it's not there
then i mean i guess you have to go like
classroom to classroom again
if it's if it's not in the library
one other thing is we did use hedwig
earlier
there was a moment when we were in the
library when we could use
hedwig so i don't know dude
maybe the owls dropped their dropped a
package up here
okay library annex
let's just take a look around
[Music]
about up here dude did we not go
wait did we not do this yet
what hold on i thought we did
all of that already
[Music]
i'm almost positive that when i came
oh yo hermione she's not petrified yet
i know it says somewhere harry
shouldn't you be at the quidditch match
uh actually we are no
dude there it is let's go let's go
no hermione we already lost the
quidditch match if you must know
way to rub it in right there okay but
here's what we're gonna do now we're
gonna go up here
and i dude i really thought we'd already
done this
i guess we're about to find out right
we're about to find out
oh we did yeah see
oh but now there's just randomly another
chest here
but all it gives you is that worthless
i thought for sure we did both of these
but
i don't know i'm going to double check
just to make sure that there's not oh
i'm
casting flupino
are you kidding me right now i did not
know that could happen guys
i really had no idea i am super pumped
we found that book though
let's go there's a dude there's more
chests
are they always just uh health items
though
oh oh another little owl treat
get away get away get away
okay let's uh let's just go back up to
gryffindor tower now
now that we got that book turn it in see
what was it cod we get
all right let's turn it in see if that's
the last one
no still not the last one are you
kidding me we're running out of room
though look at over there on the right
we're getting really close to being out
of room
lee jordan's giant tarantula are you
serious
property of lee jordan probably
wandering around the library
are you serious we were just in the
library we were just
in the library if found please return to
this notice board
all right
[Music]
see what we got uh
onoria henoria nutcombe
nutcom
wow on onoria nutcombe is what i'm gonna
go with 1665-1743
founded the society for the reformation
of hags
dude is she she's holding like a toad
and a bat over there
yo all right
[Music]
okay you know what i said we weren't
gonna gather anymore
but i feel like this might be the last
one
plus we're getting so close to the
bottom of that page that
either either we're about to go to a
second page and there's even more
than i remember or we're dangerously
close to the end so
if it was another one that's like hey
we're not going to tell you where it is
then
i wouldn't even worry about it but the
fact that they tell me it's in the
library
we'll go ahead and go for it and uh
cross your fingers that it's the last
one
back to the library we go
okay we are back inside the library
[Music]
maybe behind there oh there it is right
there right next to the cauldron
lee jordan's giant tarantula you know
what can we grab some wicked will potion
over here
because we are out
[Music]
all your vials are now full excellent
all right let's run back up
and hope come on come on that's gotta be
the last one
please if not if it's not the last one
we really are done though i promise okay
here we are once more gryffindor common
room
let's turn it in tarantula boom
i'm assuming that's the end because
nothing else is showing up it's lost
over there on the left side
all right so there we go potion skip bag
gryffindor merit badge telescope
neville's toad measuring scales wizards
hat dragon high gloves
gatting with ghouls holidays with hags
and then lee jordan's giant
tarantula give me that last wizard card
[Applause]
see what we got here oh i just messed it
up i think it was this guy though
gifford allerton 1390-1441
famous giant slayer killed the giant
hingist of upper barton
yeah that guy he does not look like a
guy he'd want to mess with
look at him man the giant axe the goatee
gifford allerton pretty tough guy
all right well i think it actually uh
this episode ran a little bit longer
than i intended we didn't even get to
the evening so that's where we'll pick
up next time
gryffindor goes down to slytherin and
quidditch but
we did find all of the notice board is
it notice board or bulletin board
hold on hold on hold on ah it doesn't
really say i think it's notice board
though
we found all the items on the notice
board and this is where we'll pick up
next time guys
as always thank you all so much for
watching if you enjoyed this video make
sure you give it a thumbs up that helps
other people find it on youtube and i
would be ever so grateful
as always thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon